oh oh hey guys so we are shopping
through the streamys I forgot my camera
so I'm borrowing Jenna's I'm not sure
than this I'm gonna need you guys to
help me choose or stress to wear for the
big event
Jenna says it was great for size it's
it's cute from all angles look a little
bit I don't know the shoes no I was
shorter a big kid how much really fault
that just looks stupid okay let's try
the next one
my idea was I wanted to be a princess
from the streamys I know that might be
good
I mean I would never normally pick this
dress out but I think I don't know I
think it looks good I did a little
something oh yeah and then like a shoes
on
it'll be good would you like me to take
a picture so you can see what it looks
like I like it on you looks like on
camera loo sparkly it's really sparkly
it's comfortable like I would be come
from the word miss all night the other
one is comfortable - right kind of issue
don't look like a princess
there's a lot of room but gets really
tight okay here's another dress option
okay breathe I don't need to breathe you
just need to live no nothing oh no you
pray something I might have dropped the
camera I'm sorry I don't think I think
it's okay I like the back oh but it's so
that's like so big yeah mmm yeah shoots
we're really counting on that one too oh
yeah what about this kick does that
cover I don't know all right guys so
those are my dress options let me know
which one you like I actually need three
dresses for three different streaming
events so rank your top three sorry
fuzzy huh
I leave me a comment below I loved the
one that you guys chose for me for the
Teen Choice Awards and it seemed to work
out pretty well and everyone seemed to
like it so thank you guys I'm really
excited to have the Streamy Awards I'm
nominated for Best first person also I
am sort of partially nominated under the
rooster teeth's gauntlet nomination for
best collaboration so I'm kind of
excited it's kind of like to two
nominees I'm just thinking don't think
too hard I love it I look like my
favorite dress I know I love it it's
cute the shoes look cute I'll see you
guys later
thank you I love you and I'm excited for
the troubies Grace and freakin Hannah
are hosting I've got a big bruise here
oh I don't know how I would cover it
makeup makeup whoo guys I'll see you
later Oh